[Musique]
capucine adam c'est votre tour dans tpm
pays ouais c'est vrai que ça faisait si
longtemps vous n'avez pas eu et on vous
aime très fort et bien marrer c'est
alors est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on vous a
manqué ce que vous nous avez manqué ou
pas vous allez vous allez dire à chaque
fois pour chaque chroniqueur si vous
avez manqué ou pas d'accord et il dira
oui ou non pour le moment moi je vous
m'avez manqué pour un truc j'aimerais
qu'on voit quand même la magnifique
chute de karoui c'est la seule fille
chute comme ça vous nous l'avez réclamé
chez vous juste pour le kiff regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pourquoi
c'est pas possible ça n'a pas de bon
la russie l'a repris le retour ce soir
on va parler bien sûr de la cei du
samedi soir du jeudi au samedi à
l'apollo théâtre est ce que pour y
inviter capucines dans ça balance à
paris
ah oui oui ce serait on a fait
connaissance je sais vous avez fait
connaissance sur les billets les anglais
chez thierry ardisson et on va voir des
extraits de l'agresseur
je sais très bien passé je sais mort des
extraits de la pièce on a hâte de voir
extrait on va tous venir vous voir venir
surtout qu'est qui mettent des pmp
si on pouvait avoir 25% ça nous ça nous
éviterait de passer par berne
voilà parce qu'une petite ristourne
voilà ça c'est toujours sympathique
quand on a déjà dit ça sert aussi
gratuitement on n'a pas envie que le
producteur perdre de l'argent
on sait ce que c'est aujourd'hui était
avec lui on sait en jouer germes il est
venu il est venu gracieux oui jean miot
6,80 alors est ce qu'à votre avis vous
manqués à l'émission selon benjamin
castaldi
ben si je pense que oui parce qu'on a le
fait la nation à côté d'accord ensemble
on discute et bien sûr en kiosque elle
vous manque
oui j'aimerais bien évidemment
qu'évidemment il vous manque d'accord à
l'aller de beinheim mascourbe du manque
et bat valérie oui mais bannis et ben
ali tout le monde lui manque un non
match pour le moment parce qu'elle a
portée étonnante fraîcheur de
spontanéité de naïveté parfois de
candeur et en même temps ils
travaillaient vraiment voilà c'était une
personnalité que j'aime beaucoup
eric mais est-ce que ça va rester tout
le temps dans ce bon esprit parce que
moi c'est pas trop mon pru
oui j'aimerais travailler est ce que je
vaux ce que vous avez manqué à gilles
verdez vous aimez beaucoup
alors comme ça je dirais non on a fait
connaissance cet été dans la télé même
l'été et oui c'est bien entendu alors
s'il n'est pas hypocrite us here et oui
alors vous pourrez alors quinze jours
gbagbo puis après je me suis dit on est
bien mieux sans elle
très très bon camarade
merci maxime kenny alors vous ne
connaissiez pas ah oui c'est vrai mais
puis un dîner et un bisou sur la bouche
thiam et parce qu'on couche je savais
pas qui vous attire en fait je découvre
les missions merci d'être là en tout cas
monsieur geoffrey c'est un plaisir et
non parce que non non parce que je ne
manque pas du tout bell lui toutes les
modes suivants
ces modèles tels que de lui s'éloignent
d'accord mais ramadan tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'elle escompte un
an qu'elle a une fraîcheur de vivre et
qu'elle a une vision ce seul jean-michel
oui les amis oui oui oui énormément
parce que on a essayé burqa on essaie ya
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont venus autour
du plateau et camus si je fais ça tu es
la seule qui a réussi à imposer ses
idées même si parfois c'était un peu
neuneu etc mais elle disait comme ce
qu'elle pense et elle arrive à trouver
nos mains nous pour le dire vite
oui c'est vrai qu'il peut alors là il va
rien à voir est-ce que capucine vous a
manqué à votre avis capitale et la ville
andine car oui oui je vais vite
publiquement ou et est en plus rien que
la première réflexion sur ce que vous
devez dire en coulisses et que vous
l'avez bien évidemment dit j'ai trouvé
que c'était formidable voilà pourquoi
j'aime capucines la seule fois où elle
m'a choqué la seule fois sur une forte
en gueule et un serveur au ski c'est la
seule fois voyez alors venez un serveur
aux skieurs du dossier de l avais je
suis pas fier
je termine le 22 décembre 2016 nous
sommes à la gaufre à deux têtes à 1800
mètres capucine and have a commandé une
tartiflette tartiflette lardons poire ou
tartiflette à la commande est il
exactement 17 minutes mais capucine
annaba fin 13 et capucine à l'absent
patiente
arrive tout à coup jean mouloud serveurs
à la gaufre à deux têtes
jambou l'aude arrive c'est et âme dans
ses bras une même une assiette avec de
la fondue une assiette avec des pâtes
mais pas de trace des tarifs le parti
fleith cet article est nous l'avons
jamais retrouvé en revanche nous avons
retrouvé un corps de jean mouloud merci
en tout cas ça la met en un seul
amendement est ce que va nous manquer
rachid arhab bas on se connaissait pas
donc non je pense que je lui manquent
pas nous qu'on sait pas qui en fait
c'est moi qui ai manqué l'année dernière
ouais voilà est-ce que tu nous as manqué
oui ou non
ah non très sincèrement non non merci
merci je suis toujours là je suis je
suis ravi que les une vraie carrière
maintenant
ah oui mais c est pourquoi devant la bim
fausse car avant les chroniqueuses
[Rires]
effectivement touche pas à mon poste a
permis de réaliser son rêve de faire de
la côte est pour l'instant c'est mon
chroniqueur préféré redescendre eu
capucine et l'émission
[Rires]
je compte sur jean-luc ans j'adorais cas
bien tout va bien le bon gars comme ça
wen tom cruise dans top gun elle après
coup de pelle vocale mais crash fida
c'est un ami oui vous l'adorez vous vous
calmez vous divine et personne dans ma
life in an parce qu'on se connaît pas
d'accord mais mais dans l'émission oui
parce qu'effectivement donc spontanéité
et fraîcheur et tous je suis totalement
d'accord
et puis j'ai toujours senti qu'elle
était une bonne carotte camarades ouais
c'est vrai tu vois et je pense que wael
a manqué à l'émission à l'amant qui a
lui même temps il manquerait plus que ça
on peut s'arrêter mauvaise qu'au regard
des tablettes ou venir sont peu la
comprends pas ça prévient route
oui oui oui je m'engage avec jay-z oui
c'est bon je veux dire ni rien de faire
chaud mais avec ces j'ai appris quelque
chose c'est de pas m'attacher aux gens
donc finalement je suis croque non non
elle m'a manqué quand même parce que
j'adore car un peu tapé chinois la
moindre pensée capucine c'est une bonne
manière pour les quatre heures c'est
vrai que vous êtes en tout cas nous on
est très heureux de vous revoir
aujourd'hui voilà non mais je suis
obligé vous êtes invités chou rouge et à
dublin oh que non mais non mais c'est
vrai vous savez on a tout le monde est
toujours en contact tous les césures le
séjour de ces débats bien sûr d'ailleurs
ce qui vous écrit ce que vous écrivez
jaune sms sur votre numéro le 06 15 70
quand même non mais c'était mal en
faisant annuler ce que les chroniqueurs
vous a manqué il y en a quelques-uns oui
oui qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus manqué
vous franchement il s'appelle ouais
c'est bien parce que j'étais assez ge à
côté d'elle tous les soirs et non
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on est bien d'accord que ton seul
argument c'est parce que tu étais assise
à côté d'elle juste pété entre elle et
moi
oui mais quand vous avez un truc bien me
le disaient ouais c'est vrai je suis
vous disais ta gueule qui ne vous manque
pas qu'ils me manquent pas majid un
vigile habana moi c'est la meilleure
nature que j'ai jamais coincé rien et
c'est même déroutant c'est tout lui va
quoi moi mais il m'a fait rire tous là
vous fais un bisou
[Applaudissements]